star trek's strange new worlds promises
to be a return to the storytelling style
of the original series but what does
that mean in 2022 keep watching to find
out
before james t kirk ever set foot on the
bridge of the uss enterprise it was
captained by christopher pike now star
trek fans will finally get to explore
the galaxy alongside this oft-forgotten
starfleet hero in star trek's strange
new worlds someone's playing fast and
loose with the rules today
i mean the boy scout
strange new worlds will premiere may 5th
2022 exclusively on paramount plus cbs
viacom's digital streaming service which
has become the home to the current era
star trek shows although captain pike
was first introduced in the unaired
pilot of star trek the original series
back in 1965 played by jeffrey hunter he
was soon replaced by william shatner who
took the role of kirk when nbc rejected
hunter's episode as too cerebral
according to shatner's memoir up till
now
strange new worlds will follow the
exploits of captain pike in a more
contained episodic format going against
a grain of serialized modern television
and a return to the formula that made
the original star trek so accessible to
viewers over so many decades
you will be joined by characters both
new and familiar and the network has
been teasing fans with a steady drip of
details so here's everything we know so
far about the release date cast and more
as the enterprise prepares once more to
boldly go where no one has gone before
the first teaser trailer for star trek
strange new worlds gives us a glimpse at
the far future universe of the paramount
plus original we see a gliding shot of
forested snowy mountains with a cabin
nestled amid the trees followed by an
original series style communicator lying
on a wood bureau next to a rotary
telephone signaling the connection to
the time period that series was first
released in 1966.
chris
[Music]
i need you back captain
next is an absolutely awesome looking
shot of pike riding a horse across the
snowy mountain terrain before a shuttle
whips past him to land on the far side
of the canyon then we see a montage of
what can only be described as well
strange new worlds some look like
futuristic cities others like barren
unexplored landscapes the trailer ends
with a shot of the original enterprise
moving at warp speed through the cosmos
and a proud looking pike in his command
uniform gazing up into the stars from
its window if this brief glimpse into
star trek's strange new worlds tells us
anything it's that the show will be a
return to the formula of the original
series where each episode is a new
adventure with new discoveries and
challenges for pike and his crew as they
seek out new life and new civilizations
how far they will boldly go remains to
be seen
just a few weeks after a 90-second
teaser trailer was released paramount
plus put out a full two-minute trailer
that gave audiences a much deeper look
at the show it opens with captain pike
beaming into a room full of squabbling
alien delegates before cutting to a
series of majestic exterior shots of the
starship enterprise in space and its
crew within as the captain describes
their mission
push the boundaries of what is known
and what is possible
interspersed are images of a team on a
comet in awe of their surroundings
dramatic shots aboard the ship and
perhaps most excitingly the sequence was
spock battling someone in a fight to the
death on vulcan more shots of pike
meaning new aliens and adventure on and
off the ship flash across the screen as
the captain says his team is the best of
starfleet we see everything from a
phaser firefight on the enterprise
bridge to characters having
heart-to-heart conversations aboard the
ship in classic trek fashion we see a
little romance too with pyke cozying up
to a woman in bed and spock laying his
lips on a fellow vulcan woman it all
gives us the sense that the show will be
a rip-roaring adventure as well as a
series with plenty of emotional drama
when captain pike arrived in star trek
discovery he was played by anson mount
and the same will be true of star trek's
strange new world alongside mounts will
be a gallery of familiar characters
played by a range of talent as well as
some newcomers who may be hiding some
fascinating secrets ethan peck returns
once more as spock who is still a
science officer yet to receive her
promotion to number one the current
first officer of pike's enterprise is
una chen reilly played once more by
rebecca romain
another character beloved by fans of the
original series is nota uhura played by
celia rose gooding like spock she's not
yet a commanding officer and the casting
reveal for strange new worlds identified
her as a cadet cadet uhura very happy to
have you aboard glad to be here the
enterprise's nurse chapel will be
another welcome return from the star
trek of the 60s portrayed this time by
just bush though he only appeared in two
episodes of the original show medical
officer dr mbenga is back on board the
enterprise and will be played by babs of
lusamongkong brand new characters abound
as well but perhaps the most fascinating
addition to the show for die hard
trekkies is christina chong's character
yuan nunyan singh the surname will be
familiar to fans who will no doubt
recall captain kirk's most bitter
nemesis kong noon yun singh writer akiva
goldsman confirms she's related to him
but is she hiding a dark secret it's
sure to be one of the most intriguing
mysteries star trek strange new worlds
will explore
while few plot specifics have been
released and the trailers are
appropriately vague producers have
mentioned a few important aspects of
star trek's strange new worlds that give
us an idea of what we can expect from
the series the biggest clue we've been
given so far is that the series will see
a return to traditional story of the
week episodes executive producer and
first episode director akiva goldsman
told trekmovie.com i really wanted to
make a show that would have appealed to
the 12 year old me that went to that
star trek convention in 1974 but that
doesn't mean that each episode will see
a hard reset or won't have long lasting
effects gold's men told the site
character arcs are still serialized our
characters will carry with them what
they suffer from or what they learned
from episode episode but the stories are
episodic meanwhile star rebecca romain
teased stories we might see in the
series first season telling looper
it's a little bit lighter we are
visiting planets we are visiting
colonies and we are so proud of our work
so far
for trek fans who have wanted to see
something more like the original series
or the next generation this should come
as music to their ears
with a series returning to classic
episodic stories of old it also means
that star trek's strange new worlds will
have the opportunity to live up to its
name anson mount who plays captain pike
told sci-fi we're going back to the big
idea of the week the new planet to the
week i think that in itself is going to
be exciting for old school fans as well
as new ones we'll also meet plenty of
new characters and alien races as
evidenced by early trailers but that
doesn't mean we won't see the return of
classic heroes villains and characters
that trek fans know and love in addition
to series regulars pulled from past trek
adventures footage screened so far has
shown a return to spock's planet vulcan
it's also shown what appears to be the
return of to pring spock's former love
first introduced in the classic original
series episode amok time they have been
bonded since childhood and it looks like
strange new worlds may explore their
relationship a little more
so while it's clear that the series is
looking to forge its own path with new
adventures make no mistake and hasn't
forgotten about the franchise's wealth
of backstory and history either and
won't be afraid to revisit at least some
of it
ever since the original series of star
trek the franchise has been known for
its self-referential nature calling back
to events and characters from earlier
episodes and movies
with nearly 60 years of stories shows
like star trek picard and lower decks
are packed with easter eggs nods to old
adventures and inside jokes for longtime
fans to catch with strange new worlds
set aboard the original uss enterprise
captained by christopher pike and
boasting a cass that includes several
other classic characters can we expect
more easter eggs and references you
better believe it rebecca romain says
fans can expect plenty of callbacks
romaine a diehard trek fan herself gave
looper some juicy details about what to
expect from the new series in addition
to describing a little bit about what
may happen in the show she said there
will be so many easter eggs for fans to
look out for from the look and feel of
the series we've seen so far it's clear
the people behind it have as much love
for trek as we do and will take care to
load the background with elements that
long time fans can have fun with
strange new worlds may take place on the
original classic starship enterprise
nearly a decade before the era of
captain kirk but the production of the
series is far from the low budget
original series and will of course
utilize the most up-to-date visual
effects and state-of-the-art alien
makeup it was confirmed by producers in
2019 that the series would use the same
ar wall technology popularized by the
mandalorian that is also being used by
sister series star trek discovery to
portray not just alien environments but
complex interiors as well during a star
trek convention appearance strange new
worlds producer henry alonso meyers
confirmed that the enterprise's new
engineering set used the ar wall to
create a bigger and more expansive
version of the original set seen in 1966
in addition the series updated the sets
and the costumes from its first
appearance on discovery season 2 with
tweaks and improvements made now that
pike spock and the enterprise are taking
a starting role hanson mounts has
commented on the rigorous covet 19
protocols followed on the set and
despite a few hiccups the production
seems to have gone relatively smoothly
with none of the behind the scenes drama
that plagued early seasons of discovery
it was confirmed in early 2022 that the
first season had completed filming with
a second season already underway some of
the cast was surprised by the early
renewal with mounts commenting that he
had presumed the series might only get a
single season
beginning on march 29th 2022 the
official twitter account star trek on
paramount plus began releasing daily
mini trailers vignettes focusing on
individual characters beginning with
cadet uhura they released brief 30
second clips for the entire main cast
the vignettes weren't the first time
we'd learned of the cast but they gave
fans a good look at each of them
reaffirming some of what we already knew
we'll see the return of classic
characters nurse chapel and dr mbenga
alongside pike number one and spock we
got a good look at alien engineer hammer
for the first time confirming that he's
not just an indorian but the subspecies
inar first seen on star trek enterprise
try it now
how did you i am a genius
the vignettes were a welcome surprise
and gave us a good feel for the tone of
the series and its characters from what
we've seen so far there should be no
doubt that strange new worlds will
embrace drama adventure exploration and
a little bit of fun they also show how
surprisingly faithful the series is
going to be to the original star trek
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]